un arma controvertida y muy tímida que
será suministrada a Ucrania por Estados
Unidos es lo que confirmó este viernes
el asesor de seguridad nacional
estadounidense Ja jalibán a pesar de sus
posibles efectos humanitarios
devastadores
reconocemos que las municiones en racimo
Crean un riesgo de daños a la población
civil debido a las municiones sin
detonar por eso Hemos aplazado la
decisión lo que se ha podido pero
también existe un riesgo masivo de daño
civil si las tropas y los tanques rusos
pasan por encima de las posiciones
ucranianas toman más territorio
ucraniano y subyugan a más civiles
porque Ucrania no tiene suficiente
artillería las bombas de racimo ya están
siendo utilizadas tanto por las fuerzas
rusas como por las fuerzas ucranianas en
la guerra son cohetes que dispersan
múltiples pequeños explosivos en un
amplio rayo y dejan tras de sí pequeñas
bombas sin explotar lo que supone una
amenaza para la población civil durante
años causando muertes y mutilaciones
Naciones Unidas han pedido a Rusia y
Ucrania que dejen de utilizar municiones
de racimo más de 100 países firmaron una
convención que prohíbe estas bombas
el secretario general apoya la
convención sobre municiones de racimo
que como saben se adoptó hace 15 años y
quiere que los países cumplan los
términos de esa convención y como
resultado por supuesto no quiere que se
sigan utilizando municiones de racimo en
el campo de batalla
Estados Unidos afirma que sólo en yara
municiones de Última Generación con un
menor porcentaje de bombas caídas es
decir que no explotan por su parte
Ucrania acogió con satisfacción la
decisión afirmando que necesita Estas
armas para derrotar